expresa en la forma de un mono vio como
no vio al área de un rectángulo que mide
4 x de largo y 12 de ancho ok
mono mió mono mío lo que significa es
que es un solo término puede tener
muchas cosas multiplicándose por ejemplo
x cuadrada porque a las 5 x 12 pero el
chiste es que no se le sume a ninguna
otra cosa que tenemos el área de un
rectángulo que mide 4 x de largo a ver
dibujemos nuestro rectángulo y de largo
mide 4 x xi y de ancho mide 2 y entonces
queremos sacar el área pero el área
el ar
de un rectángulo siempre es base por
altura o sea tomamos las longitudes de
los lados y las multiplicamos entonces
aquí nos queda que el área es igual a 2
g por 4x
ok entonces ya nada más tenemos que
simplificar esta expresión aquí tenemos
2 x 4 por ejemplo que es igual a 8
siempre siempre que estamos
multiplicando dos expresiones de este
tipo
podemos reacomodar los términos okay
siempre que todas estas cosas estén
multiplicando si hay un más por allí en
medio ya no las podemos reacomodar pero
este está multiplicándose con este con
éste y con este entonces los podemos
reordenar y nos queda 2 x 4 que es 8
después por aquí tenemos una equis
solita
y por aquí este y podemos pensar que es
he elevado a la potencia 1 y este otro y
también podemos pensar que es llegue a
la 1 y a la hora de multiplicar nos
podemos simplemente decir ya sé por qué
tiene que ser cuadrada o podemos ver que
tenemos la misma base que es elevado a
distintas potencias y entonces nada más
sumamos las potencias y entonces nos
queda en la base elevado a 1 más 1 2
ok entonces el área
área del rectángulo es igual a 8x de
cuadrada y este sí es un mono mío